The right answer, either SPIN or monolithic, will result in the least number of
border crossings. Why? In the microkernel based
structure, we're assuming that each one of
these services are available as server processes.
In their own hardware address space and
therefore any system service that an application
needs may have to go through multiple
border crossings. And by border crossing we, of
course, mean going across different address spaces and
the incumbent loss of locality that it entails.
Whereas, in the case of mono, you have
only two border crossings. One to get to
the monolithic kernel and the other to come
out back into the application. And by construction,
in SPIN also, because we are taking SPIN and
extending it with the services. They're all
contained in the same hardware address space.
So, even though we may be going
through several different protection domains in satisfying the
system call emanating from an application. Those
prediction domains are all logical prediction domains.
It does not involve border crossing that
entails change of locality and loss of performance.